[音楽]
[拍手]
えっとみなさんこんにちは
えっと青木いうと言います僕は今日本に来る枚黒人観光客向けのウェブメディアの会社
を経営しています
今日お話ししたい内容は剣大剣にこそ価値があるという言葉についてお話しさせて
ください
これは自分が大事にしている版画絵なんですけれど
今の地雷ってすごいいろんな情報にあふれていてスマートフォンがあることでどこでも
情報を得ることができて
どこでも発信することができると情報に溢れている時代だと思います
そんな時代だとよくあるのがイッツデモいないんですけど何聴いただけでわかった気に
なってしまう
そういったことたくさんあるなぁと
を感じていますがこんな時代だからこそ自分の体験を軸にする生き方そういったことが
大事になるのかなと考えています
それの理由としては人は体験によって今が作られるからだと思っているからです
一つ一つの選択日にいろんな選択や決断を
人はしているんですけれどその体験の決断の軸としているのって誰かガッキーのは聞い
た情報というのももちろんあるんですけれど自分がそれは大事だとか自分はそう
がたいそれを体験した情報ということが多いと考えています
僕は明治の国際日本学部という大学に入学して卒業しました
この額は人と変わっていて日本の漫画坂アニメとかファッションとか日本の伝統芸とか
日本語とか日本の文化というものを学問として学んで世界に発信できる人を増やそう
そういったコンセプトの楽曲だったんですねで
そういった学部だったんで日本に対しの監視どんどん高まっていたんですけど
とある教授は日本の文化は世界で流行っているけれど日本人はそこでビジネスできて
ない
そんな話をしてたんですねう僕はそれを聞いた時チャンスだと思ったんです
いい曲だなぁと思ってっていうのは10朝の時世界一周にいくって決めていて
昭和
独立すると決めていたんですなのでこれから海外を回っていくにあたって日本のものは
同形られているか見ながら旅をしをそういうふうに思って実際に世界一緒に行きました
入った期間としては2011年6月から7カ月間ほど1年休学をしてあの回りました
いろんな体験をしたんですけれども例えばあの真ん中の写真これはを刺し
なんですけれど弾よく見るとわかると思うんですけどおにぎりみたいにパッケージされ
てるんですよね
でこれはイギリスのロンドンで行っていればサビっていうお店で
僕が入った時はあの4店舗くらいターンてだったんですけれど5年後の今もう20店舗
以上拡大している店になってます実際行ってみて
全然美味しくなかったんですけれどそこにいろんな人の行列が出来たりしていてこう
いうふうに日本のものって
外に発信されているんだなとそれで一個下の写真でこれはイタリアの物価という
イベントなんですけれどあのコミックあのゲームフェスティバルっていう
体で世界中のコミックとゲームを展示するようなイベントなんですね
で
まぁ実際4日間で20万人がいくるイベントなんですけど実際行ってみると
世界のっていうふうに銘打ってにもかかわらず置いてあるバンバーコミックの7割日本
の万羽だったりしました
でもそこになかなか日本人がビジネスできてなかったりとかそういったことを旅を通じ
て感じたんですね
で
まあそういう世界史を得て僕が思ったのこの領域で何か挑戦していきたいなって思って
思いました
で同時に思ったのは自分は日本のことを全然知らないなって思ったんです
日本ってどんな国なのとか東京以外になにが面白いのとか惹かれた際に全力応えられ
ない自分もいました
なので大学に戻ってそこから日本を巡る旅っていうのを
大学の休みの時間だったりとか使って回りました
実際いろんな所を回ったんですけれど持ち地域によさってたくさんあったんですね
ただそういったよさというものを僕自身知らなかった同時にいろいろ回って話を聞いて
思ったのがその地域の良さというものが今どんどんなくなっていると
でも日本の坂ブラを例にすると30年前は3200パシャッたらいませんカ所ぐらいと
言われています
それは東京にお家て僕は戦闘がすごい好きなんですけど
20202000年のころは2000て2000個ぐらいあった
あの戦闘が今600パシャになってるっていう話をこないだ聞きましたが日本の良い
文化ってたくさんあるんですけれどそれを知られないが良いなくなってるって言うの
あの実際痛感したんですね
ああああああ
そんな時に何かしたいなーって考えた際にとある経営者がこんなことを言ってました
自分がやりたいこととこれからの時代はマジアルペンを仕事にした方がいい
そんなことを言われたんですね
で自分がやりたい事って何かというと自分が好きなことです
で自分が好きなことって何かというと追求したりとかやりきれることなんですね
でこれからの時代に何かというとこれから伸びていくことです
伸びていくて何かというと挑戦できたりいろんなチャンスがある領域のことを言います
これらが重なる点を仕事にした方が絶対いいよって言われたんですね
で木に撮ってそれでなんだったかっていうとやりたいほどっていうのは日本のことを
世界に発信していく
それによって残していくことをやりたいなと思いました
これからの時代と何かなって思った時にちょうど会社を作るって決めた年ですね
オリンピックが決まりました2020年これから日本全体がそこに対象に企業がたかま
あっていくだろうと同時に今旅行自体と言われていて
あの lcc が普及してきたことによってどんどん移動しやすくなってるんですね
東京から大阪の往復よりも東京から台湾でも服のが安い
そんな時代に混ざってます
でアジアはどんどん成長していくによってことによってそこからの人の動きとかも増え
ていくとそういったことがわかっていたのでこれらが課せられて心を仕事にしたいなと
思いました
実際2013年の12月3日
今が4年前ですね3年と3ヶ月マンにあの会社を作りました
でその2か月後に抹茶というメディアを立ち上げました
今も続けていて会社のメンバーの4割台が外国籍のようなそんな会社になっています
って何がきっかけだったかというところで言うとあのいろんなきっかけがあってこれが
一つがすごい影響を与えたっていうことを当然あるんですけどそれが決定的だったって
ことってあまりないんですよね一つ一つの体験の積み重ねが今の自分をつくってるなと
感じています
ただその中で自分の中で意識してきたことをこれをやって良かったことというのは一つ
あってそれを皆さんに共有させてください
それが人生でやりたい100のリストというものです
ここにいる方でもしかしたら作られている方っていらっしゃるかもしれないんです
けれど僕はこれを5年前に作って
あのセラ自分にとってすごいよかったなぁと思っていますこれ何かっていうと自分が
やりたい事っていうのも紙でもいいですし
パソコンでもいいのでキャップを吐き出してみるということです
実は少しすごい大変で自分も100個作るまで大体一周考えがかかりました最初40個
ぐらいは出るんですけどそこからなかなか出ない
あれ自分がやりたいことで何だろうって最初わかんなくなるぐらい出なかったんですね
d 者100校だスキルとこういうことやりたかったんだって気づくことができました
一つやっぱり忘れてしまうものなのでそれをどこでも見える錠剤にしようと思って自分
がこれブロー自分のブログに貼りだしたんですね
で結果としてどうなったかというと
100個出してしました
これは4年前に味は1年前に達成したんですけれど
でも100個達成したときにやりたいことって実はもう350個ぐらい出ていてその
うちの100個達成したっていう形です
ちょうど昨日見てみたら107ぽやっていました
で
何をやったかってよくいくつかなんですけど例えば今の自分をからしてみたら当たり前
なことなんですけど
macbook air を買ったっていうのはありましたそれによってあの外でも
仕事をして着る習慣だって仕事に触れる時間増えたりあと近いシュウマイカメラを買っ
たんですねカメラが欲しいの一眼レフが欲しいなと思って
なかなか買う機会がなかったんですけど旅前に買おうと思って6万があれだけでや買い
ました
それによって写真を撮るのが好きになったり人に伝えることが写真を通じてできるよう
になったり
またこの写真は良い写真がどうかとかそういった判断もできるようになりました
これは最初のバックパッカーの旅行です大学3年の時に
夏休に12週間ほど海外を旅しました
最初体幹も思案マレーシアに参加国ですね2週間かけて一人旅をしたんですけどここで
の経験が結果として世界一周の旅につながりますこれは最後サンフラ
cisco から羽田に向かう便の写真です
で僕は他のなっちゃっていうメディアを作ったんですけれどそのメディアを作った
きっかけというのもブログが始まりだったんですね
自分がブログを始めたことでそれによって多くの人が見てくれたんですってみてくれた
ことによって誰かアクションしてくれましたそれは自分に返ってきたっていう経験が
あったんですね
それを何か社会化できないかなっていうふうに考えた際にメディアをやるというふうに
やって抹茶というメディアを作りました
僕のやつが一番最初の時のデザインです
目の前のが最近のデザインですだいぶ変わりました
これはこれも4年前ですね導きカウチサーフィンというものでマイクの人を切れたん
ですけどその時にイスラエルの人が
あの一切人イスラエル人の同い年の方があの家に訪ねてきました
で実際に明日どうしようかなどこ行こうかなっていう声をもらったんですね
デイ際に調べてもなかなか日本の情報で当時10出なかったんですよね
で自分はここがいいよここがいいよここはいいよって言うことをお勧めして
でそこが何だろうな今目の前に課題があって自分がやりたいことで今やっていることに
つながっているかなと考えています
これは最近の会社です会社をつくっ会社を作るということも自分でやりたいことの1つ
だったんですけど
会社をつくったことでやりたいことがどんどん増えていったんですね
まあ例えばを思想をもう少し大きくしたいとか今トイレは一つしかないんですけど
2つ作りたいとかあとは卓球台を受けるようにしたい
卓球だよ
シールすっていう風に書いたら実際に卓球台が知り合いから送られてきたりし0
で会社のメンバーをもっと増やす増やしたいという良い年バー持って集めたいって思っ
ていたことで気づいたら中24人の会社になったり
なくそんなことがあの何か一つをやったことによっておきました
そこで自分が感じるのは自分がやりたいことっていうのは自分の体験からしか生まれ
ないだと思うんですね
例えばホーム読んだことがなくて文章を書いたことがない人が小説家になりたいかって
絶対ならないと思うんですよね
やっぱり人っていうのは自分が体験したことちょっと面白そうだなと思ってくれて
良かったことが結果としてやりたいことにつながっていく
そういうふうに思っています
その体験が連鎖していくとこれは自分自身に対して連鎖していく場合もあるんですね
会社をつくったことによってこれをやりたくなったとかもあるんですけれどそれは同時
に1に対して連鎖することっていうのもあります
自分が体験して良かったことってや人に話すんですよ
これ式を良かったとかこれ本当におすすめだよって話すんですよね
そうするとこの10人に1人は実際にそれをやってくれたりするんですよ
その人が良い体験をするとそれまた枝いかに伝えたりします
なのでいい体験だったりとかっていうのはどんどん連鎖していくということがあるなぁ
と思っています
ねぇこれは最近すごい考えることなんですけれど今自分たちがやってる方日メディア
まあメディアなんですけど正解も不正解
ないんですよねそれはいろんな分野でもいえるなぁと思っていて
で何か新しいことを始めると絶対トラブルって起きるんですよ
何か邪魔が起きるいろんな問題起きてしまうんですよ
そういうときにあぁ辛いなあとか大変だなって思うことがあるんですけどそこで大事な
のはやり抜いていくことなんですよね
やり抜いていく上で大事になるのが自分の中で確信を持てるかどうかということが大事
だと思っています
これは正しいっていうふうに決めてやっていくかどうか
僕はそれの聞いていうのは
は自分自身の体験現在県にあると思っています
最後になるんですけれど僕はこれからの時代に許可していくと思っています
これからどんどんま vr だったり ai だったりとかいいテクノロジーが進化し
ていって自分や情報ってもっと増えていくんですよねその情報だけで満足しやすくなっ
てしまう地帯になると思います
ね何で1つは情報で満足してしまう人で2つ目は自分の体験を軸に何かを語って何かを
実行していく人そういうふうに許可していく時代になると思っています
僕はその一人一人のその体験一つ一つの体験というものが新しい何かにつながっていく
そう思うとこの
価値観を持っていくだけで全然変わっていくものってあるかなと
ここにいる方で何か踏み出せないとかこれやりたいけどやれないとか興味あるな
けどやってないとかっていう人っていると思うんですよねそういった人は是非その想い
をぜひ形にしてもらいたいです
それを体験に変えてもらいたいですそれによって自分自身前に進むこともあると思い
ます
4その自分自身のまあ一歩が誰かの一歩につながっていく
そんなことが起きていくと思います
自分からのあのプレゼンは以上になります
ご静聴ありがとうございました